there is much about me I would not have
him know so you value a privacy more
than your son I'm going to cut off your
head no good enough one of my favorite
noir squads to appear in the new code of
war without a shadow of a doubt his
Mamere and today we'll attempt to answer
any questions that you may have about
Mamere how he's rolling the game
compares to that of his role in Norse
mythology itself as always of these
videos there will most likely be
spoilers so if you don't want to have
the story spoiled I urge you to please
click away now were first introduced to
Mamiya when he's being questioned by
Boulder and the sons of Thor Modi and
Magni as to the whereabouts of Kratos in
the trees unwilling to help the trio he
insists that they leave and it's right
off that is that he first encounters
Kratos init Reyes when they offer to
free him from the tree that he's been
trapped in he tells him that there is a
spell placed by Odin that will not allow
his body to leave in order to help a
trace and Kratos on their journey they
would have to cut off his head and take
it to the witch in the woods what would
be resurrected when they do eventually
managed to revive his head he then
accompanies them to Jotunheim acting as
someone of a guide offering them advice
and useful pieces of information along
the way he does also provide some
much-needed comic relief to contrast the
overall serious tone of Kratos it's
during the first encounter that we
witnessed between boulder and Mamere
that border describes him as been the
smartest man alive to which she replies
that he smarts and all the dead ones -
and this concept of who may be an
extremely clever is definitely one that
manifests itself within Norse mythology
Mamiya was thought to roughly translate
to mean the rememberer
and he was seen as being exceptionally
wise when the gods were need of counsel
they would visit mimir there were only a
handful of surviving accounts where
Mia's physical appearance is described
which makes it very difficult for us to
tell if he was either an ace a god or
one of the owner the relationship
between Mamere and Odin in the game
resembles out of Norse mythology with a
few slight changes we know that mermaid
did serve Odin in the icier as an
advisor but he was never particularly
fond of the icy in order to keep the
peace he advised Odin to marry Freya to
bring the vania and icy tribes together
throughout the game he does make it very
clear that he harbors a great deal of
resentment for Odin and Thor in
particular having been tortured every
day for 100 years by Odin it's
understandable that Mamiya was more than
willing to be decapitated by Kratos if
it meant he could escape the confines of
his tree the concepts of Mamere being
beheaded and then later having his head
revived was actually taken directly from
Norse mythology as during the war
between the venire and I see
Mamiya was actually beheaded by the
venire upon seeing the severed head of
his most valued advisor owed him with an
embalmed the head of a mixture of spices
incantations and songs that would all
help preserve the Mia's head in terms of
dire need
Odin was then consult of the head as it
was still able to provide incomparable
advice throughout Norse mythology
mamuro's regarded as the chief force
behind the wisdom of past tradition and
there was no other being that possessed
the level of knowledge that could even
rival Mamere perhaps the most well known
story that many features in is the story
of why Odin only has one eye located
deep beneath the roots of the world tree
Yggdrasil lies me miss verda near the
Old Norse former me as well sometimes
also referred to as the will of Earth it
was believed that a vast source of
mamiya's knowledge came from drinking
the water located in his well and Odin
been on a quest for knowledge wouldn't
do anything to understand the meaning of
life in the cosmos would eventually
journey to me as well after a long and
tiresome journey
Odin eventually arrived asking me if he
could take a drink from his well as the
Guardian we may decline unless Odin was
willing to sacrifice something of equal
worth that sacrifice was indeed his eye
valuing knowledge above everything after
a small period of contemplation Odin
eventually gouged out his own eye and
dropped it into the well who was the
sacrifice now made ramier took his great
horn and filled it with water given Odin
a drink
Odin was filled with vast amounts of
knowledge and he was given the gift of
sight being able to see things that had
not happened yet is also thought that
the god Heimdall may have visited with
me as well and sacrificed an ear in
return for his heightened sense of
hearing
murmurs gives a sight in the game is
attributed to his eyes which were
magical jewels given to him by the
Giants that signify the gift of sight
there are no actual accounts of Amir
being tortured by Odin but the Odin we
hear about in God of War is far more
angry paranoid and controlling than
their did we see in Norse mythology
Mamiya gives us this extremely
interesting figure in both Norse
mythology and God of War itself you have
this witty sarcastic character who
contrasts very well of the Serie stone
of Kratos but also literally serves as a
well of wisdom as always I'd love to
hear from you guys how much of Mia's
story did you actually know before god
of war is he a character you're
particularly fond of and do you think
we'll ever see him with a body in a
future game let me know in the comments
below